we're in Paris simmer pretty much all
dying we're sick so we have to make do
the best that we can we're currently in
the battle clan which is a nice little
[Music]
there's only two dressing rooms we've
got the bottom of the tube and then
there's the upstairs one hi City of
Brotherly Love city of broad shoulders
city that never sleeps
you missed a big apple welcome to Paris
did you hear about the mmm look at
Michael Scott he is so not very loud
panting child it like Charles in Charge
because they're really offensive we
could hear you all the way down stair
being all like Perry you guys are both
offensive and like well what do you have
to say for yourself weird Bob and Tyler
go it's magic all right we're moving out
we're gonna we're not going to the
Eiffel Tower we're going all around
I'm sick oh my gosh you choose you these
are lovely bus drivers all right so
we're gonna get out here
you think this is a good vlogging angle
this is all I can be done I could this
is all I can be bothered to do I look
less like a vlogger and more just like a
tourist that doesn't know how to use a
camera
I love rants this is a very close-up of
my mouth oh the Bob got left behind
Bob hey all right let's go
I don't like that man like this Alice
this alley is a little bleeding do
something dangerous there's an example
of the French boy no legs pit stop
Picasso Museum that's all we stop for
food okay we got meat
we got ham got pickles cuz I face my
fears Brett I'm done now I'm done now
I'm done it's all done
yeah we're leaving now
we're leaving we're back now I don't
know what happened we were fine and then
suddenly I started feeling sick I don't
know why I don't think I'm gonna be able
to sing tonight
also Ethan's sick neither do I so we're
gonna have to deal with what we got I
play football lead with the helmet of a
bird squawk that didn't seem right I'm
losing my voice I've already lost my
voice hello everybody
that looks like you're trying to pano
everybody hello everybody welcome to the
show how are you doing wait people don't
use zooms enough am i right I am zooming
as much as I can Wow that's a good zoom
that's the last sight you see before you
die definitely 100% no no
[Music]
hey wait come look at this cool huh
Ethan come check this out
check it out right that's not what I was
doing
yes I do all right Wade you give it a go
[Laughter]
I'm trying to find a way to get free
coke a cold huh
aren't we all wait aren't we all just
trying to find a way
free coke a cola
we're in Paris good you're doing a
great job Phil do you have our coke all
right guy go bye
fans are ecstatic we're in Paris right
now I don't know what day or what time
it is but we're gonna rock it and I
can't sweep you off of your feet
fill your mouth still remember the taste
my love hey I lost my voice
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'm out of here all right listen up
this is how it's gonna go
we're gonna go out on the stage get some
of that just like that we're gonna kick
ass that walls the ass and these shoes
my ass oh yeah
oh we're halfway through baby it's
intermission time and you know what that
means time max no I was gonna say time
to time to mentally read I look at me
time to mentally recharge hello
everybody thank you for watching this
amazing video my voice is completely
gone so there isn't a real outro to fill
that void in your life you should go
look up pictures of cute elderly couples
bye-bye
you